today we're talking about access
management
free skill building and call of duty
i'm jenny and welcome to this week in
cloud where we serve you
the lowest latency news to minimize
management effort
and the risk of an oversight it
administrators often prefer centralized
access control
to achieve this we've released im
database
authentication for cloud sql and mysql
into general availability with iam
database authentication
administrators can use cloud identity
and access management
to govern not only administrative access
but also connection access for their
mysql databases
check out the blog for more specifics
and how to get started
earlier this year we launched the google
cloud skills challenge
which provides 30 days of free access to
training to build your cloud knowledge
and an opportunity to earn skill badges
that showcase your google cloud
competencies
now we're adding a native app
development track to the skills
challenge
for cloud developers who want to learn
to build serverless web apps
and google assistant applications on
google cloud using cloudrun
and firebase millions of people view
action-packed esports and a new
revolutionary project that we're working
on with call of duty league
using bigquery and looker just made that
action
a lot better activestack an entirely new
capability for esports
brings fans players and commentators the
power of competitive statistics in real
time
call of duty league will roll out active
stat during the 2021 season
so check out the blog post for more
details
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list
check out the link any thoughts or ideas
leave us a comment or tweet us we'll see
it in the cloud